[Music]
well it looks like Prince Harry and that
woman from La that he married are
running out of money how do we know that
because they're still talking about
themselves selling the most boring
little details from their boring little
lives for more money so to that end
Prince Harry has just resorted to
telling us even more about a dramatic
physical altercation you had with his
brother which wasn't actually that
dramatic quote he sat down the water
called me another name and then came at
me he says in his new book yeah huh
but for some reason a lot of media
outlets in this country are deeply
invested in the details of this boring
man's boring life here's Good Morning
America for example
the quote in this book will you refer to
your brother as your beloved brother and
arch nemesis strong words what did you
mean by that
there is always being
this competition
between us weirdly I think it really
plays into always played by the air
spare
oh so two brothers who had tension
between them breaking news on Good
Morning America
if you're from Great Britain and these
are the people who are supposedly
technically the head of state of your
country what do you make of all of this
this embarrassing spectacle well we
thought it was time to check in with
Father Calvin Robinson who's an Anglican
Deacon from that country who joins us
tonight to assess father thank you so
much for coming on I mean
how is this going over in your country
uh Tucker first of all happy New Year
um how is it going over I think we're
all sick and tired of Harry and Megan
whining and moaning and going on and on
well most of us are anyway you know at
first when I first saw these headlines I
thought okay this is annoying this is
frustrating they're being disparaging
about the monarchy again which of course
is family to them but to us it's an
institution at the very fabric of our
nation but I'm past frustration I
actually feel sorry for Harry now he's
using really juvenile language he's he
seems quite immature to be honest he's I
don't know any other grown man that
talks about their private parts as their
todger you know he talks about mounting
a woman and it's the kind of
conversation I expect to hear in a
primary school Just In that clip you
just showed he talks about his brother
as his arch nemesis how many adults have
an arch nemesis is he seems to live in a
fantasy world you know in the excerpts
we saw that um Megan was singing to
seals and Harry said she's magical
because the seals sang back I'm like
this this these people are delusional
this is not good they need to seek help
they need to stop talking to the Press
stop airing their dirty laundry and
actually get some professional medical
help
I I wonder I mean Europe obviously a man
of the cloth it what does it do to your
soul if you never stop talking about
yourself
exactly it's the inner narcissism it's
not good it eats away at you it's not
just talking about yourself it's the
fact that they don't seem to take any
Agency for themselves either there's no
personal responsibility you know in a
few of these excerpts we've seen that
Harry says oh actually it was Will and
Kate who made me wear that knots uniform
and you're thinking you're again you're
a grown adult you don't have to wear a
knots uniform to a fancy dress party if
you don't find it funny you clearly
chose to do so don't blame everyone else
and the same you know he goes on to say
that he had this altercation with his
brother and this is a trained Army
serviceman who's saying I had a fight
with my brother I had to go to seek
therapy for that it's like first of all
you are a killer you're talking about
how many people you've killed in service
which of course is uncouth no one talks
about how many people they killed in
service but then on the other hand of
the argument you're saying oh I had an
argument with my brother and I had to go
and get a therapy about it none of it
seems to add up it's not balanced he
does need prayer I think he needs all
about prayer they both do and they need
something more professional too
yeah I mean no I think and you make a
fair point that no one can make you wear
a Nazi uniform to a dinner party you did
that
father Calvin Robinson of the United
Kingdom thank you so much subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight